let's uh we'll we'll do a ridiculous
segue and we'll talk about dr peterson i
have been so excited about this yeah so
um i i had to respond to jordan peterson
uh the new york post reports
sports illustrated swimsuit cover model
critic jordan peterson quits twitter
after backlash bye for now i told lydia
his away message should have just said
no fatties oh right for sure so
there's a new york post posted this uh
morbidly obese woman on the cover of
sports illustrated and dr jordan
peterson said sorry not beautiful and no
amount of authoritarian tolerance is
going to change that
i
i thought it was really funny i thought
it's tweet and i i think him deciding
you know jordan i think he's great i'm a
big fan i think him deciding to get away
from twitter for a little bit is
probably a good idea for sure sheamus
put it well you said oh just about
picking your battles choose your battles
man there's something in that i kind of
feel like
when you when you when you're swimming
in the swamp for too long
actually is a better way to put it be
careful uh when fighting monsters unless
you become one for when you gaze into
the abyss the abyss cases back peterson
would know that and so when i saw this i
kind of felt like are you calling fat
people monsters
no i kind of feel like
here's here's the issue let me show you
these photographs
here here's cosmo we've mentioned before
this is healthy it's a morbidly obese
woman here's another morbidly ob someone
says this is healthy
i i think these are awful i think these
are dangerous i think they're wrong
i think you should not encourage people
to be unhealthy
obesity can cause cancer there's a big
row in the uk because there was an ad
that was put up that said the number i
think was like the number one cause or
like number two cause of cancer or
something and it was obesity you need to
guess the letter and people are like
this is fat shaming
so they they also had the beach body ad
of like beautiful men taken down our
place with fat women i'm like that
i can understand when they're trying to
encourage
there's a cover of sports illustrated
they put a fat chick on it my response
was yo dr peterson some guys like fat
chicks like let them have their day that
was my favorite take dude but also it's
like the fact that the argument went
from don't sexually objectify women to
like make sure you're more inclusive
with your sexual objectification exactly
so strange that's literally where the
left went like no the larger women
should be objectified as well my
favorite part
my favorite part of the day was after
you tweeted that imagining all my old
liberal friends being like oh no do i be
mad at tim poole or jordan peterson and
having to like
pick a side and just heads exploding
everywhere you know you know it's funny
it's how it works on twitter is if um
they they don't see the things i tweet
unless someone screen grabs it and the
only reason they'll screen grab it is if
they can mock it sure so when there are
tweets where i'm just like yeah like let
you know some people like fat chicks
like so funny let them have their day
you know what i mean i was just like i'm
not
look
say encouraging it saying it's healthy
partly they're partly encouraging it
they're they're they're they're putting
on the cover of magazines but i'm also
just like i'm i'm not
i'm not too concerned about them showing
a morbidly obese woman on the cover of
sports illustrated but i do have
questions and so the one thing i would
say is if jordan peterson criticized it
appropriately i would i would be total
agreement
about it what he said was authoritarian
tolerance not beautiful it was yeah it
was like it was like taking a
sledgehammer to uh you know like a wood
nail and it was so easy because then
everyone just started posting sad
pictures of jordan peterson and i was
saying i mean he could have just maybe
texted a slightly cuter member of the
like intellectual dark web just shot sam
harris hey can you post this sam's got
dreamy eyes yeah i don't know i mean i
agree with you on the health thing i
when i taught jiu jitsu um
i've i've had a lot of people come to me
because they were overweight and they
were
really sad about it and they were
embarrassed about it and i don't i
haven't talked about this publicly
recently i wrote about it like a decade
ago but i've struggled with binge eating
i mean you would call it an eating
disorder if it was a woman you would say
i have an eating disorder
food issues are hard man and the times
i've been overweight i've hated myself
and i still have body dysmorphia even
though i train every day
and
but what you're saying about health is
so important number one if you just
quote unquote if you actually fat shame
people not what the left say is fat
shaming if you actually fat shame people
that's not gonna help them right if i
see someone down the street i'm like hey
fatty or whatever they're not gonna be
like oh i better get to a jujitsu class
they're gonna hate themselves more and
by the way same with what but sheamus
would laugh and then high-five you and
that would feel really why are you
why are you making this about me
he would never he'd be like yeah what
are you talking about
what have i ever indicated that that
would be my response to someone heckling
a stranger
the the craziest fat champion story i
have when i had the old progressive
podcast and i told this on a rogan i
think but it still horrifies me is
there's a dude who wrote in and he said
his doctor
said yeah same deal morbidly obese
essentially said he's gonna die and he
had kids and was like i don't know what
to do so i wrote him an email i sent him
a bunch of healthy recipes i found him a
jujitsu place i actually emailed uh tim
spriggs who ran the judicial school was
like oh i remember that guy
six months later eight months later
whatever it is
he writes into the show and he goes hey
dude my doctor just said
he's never seen such a quick turnaround
before
my kids are so proud of me and i'm and
i'm entering my first white belt jiu
jitsu okay cool now lydia you're
reacting like a normal human being right
right
we got
six to ten emails the next day saying by
reading that email we were fat shaming
them and that's when i go and i was
still in my most progressive most woke i
was like you would rather this dude die
and orphan his kids then temporarily
feel bad about yourself and maybe let
that inspire you to i'm not saying if
you don't do jiu jitsu you're a fatty
right i'm not saying it's a totalitarian
whatever authoritarian yeah i don't do
jiu-jitsu not beautiful yeah sheamus
but hold on but can i ask you something
would it be helpful if like you had a
personal trainer who's like you are
going to be an authoritarian patty like
you need to lose the weight make this
app dude the jordan peterson weight loss
app yes we have that's another sketch
that's another i said clean your room
not
love that that's your
good
just a bunch of lobsters going shame
shame shame shame i love it can i just
say before we move on this was my red
pill when i was 11 years old yeah i
looked at the healthy at every size move
and i was like these ladies are not
healthy and i want to say there are two
things here one is subjective that is
beauty you and everyone else is welcome
to think that this lady is beautiful
she's very pretty hundred percent she's
solidly chunky queen she is a chunky
queen she is thick with three c's and i
there's no problem with that i
appreciate it however the other is the
objective and this is what i was seeing
when i was 11. i was like dude these
ladies are not healthy this is not good
this lady is not athletic i'm not sure
why she's on the cover of
sports illustrated i don't think she
plays the sport other than i don't know
hot dog hot dog
the eye contact you two made before that
line came out was beautiful
but anyway it's like she's not healthy
and i know this isn't going to be good
for her down the line now tess holliday
really troubles me because she's
literally like tim is just cracking i'm
just imagining sports illustrated doing
like the 12th annual recovery
i see it no don't predict the future
stop this stuff it's not okay tess
holidays like 400 pounds she's like i'm
so proud of myself i'm so healthy i'm
like
b word no you're not you absolutely
aren't like i don't want anyone to hate
themselves right like i don't
it's sad it's sad to think of someone
hating themselves because they're fat
and there are a lot of people i'm sure
even listening to this show who's spiral
about that but it's and but it's
it's worse to hate yourself so much that
you end up in denial and you're it's the
same as when you tell your friends hey
i'm gonna quit drinking because you have
a drinking problem and your other
friends are drinking problems you're
like well is your problem that you're a
little [ __ ] and they're trying to get
you to keep drinking it's like bro if
i'm an alcoholic and you are pushing me
to do it so you can feel better about
you know drinking on the weekends
because you don't want to see your wife
and little spike kids then it's like
that's on you like that's messed up
i'm i'm
legit thinking that the future of sports
illustrated is going to be a whole bunch
of really nice stuff yeah yeah because
like angrily tweeting well we know
because
have you ever seen what's that what's
that morbidly obese woman's clothing
store oh
yeah oh lord like they they have
mannequins that are morbidly obese oh
interesting and they just tie five other
i
mannequins
together
i don't know if we can jump on youtube
for saying anyway no but i but i'm like
mannequin shaming there's a conspiracy
theory
you know the dove real beauty campaign
yeah
uh
do you know who owns dove what what's
the parent company of dove no it's a
unilever yeah oh no unilever unilever
owns another another brand i don't know
ben jerry's oh boy
so there was a conspiracy theory that
they were you know for at a higher level
we're looking at like we want women to
eat more ice cream i was wondering why
the woman in the shower using dove was
eating cherry garcia
so i'm pretty sure it was like a meme
about it but i mean it makes sense if
you're in a business and you're like we
want to sell soap to women and we also
want to sell ice cream but all these
super thin models are making people not
want to buy ice cream put the fat women
in the soap commercial and the women
will be like that's like me and they'll
eat ice cream
and then sports illustrated will have
ice cream eating contests and they're
magazine what i mean is if if the
average woman is obese
then sports illustrated is going to
start putting more and more obese women
on the cover so with the body positivity
thing i want to sort of piggyback on
something lydia said i actually i don't
agree with the idea that beauty is
subjective i do believe it's objective
there are some elements of our like
experience of it which is subjective
stop putting on me i know well
[Laughter]
but my problem is that you know what the
body positivity could have been a fact
movement could have been effective at is
saying something like look
not everyone is physically beautiful in
the same way but just because someone
isn't beautiful doesn't give you the
right to treat them poorly because a
person's value is not limited to their
physical appearance and someone
shouldn't be treated poorly because they
don't look good and so instead they
decided to say actually everyone looks
good
what did that do that solidified this
idea that actually appearance is what
gives you your value because if we tell
you you don't look good then we are
telling you your worth
because that's what we believe so we
just have to instead of challenging our
understanding of what beauty means we
have to say no no everyone's beautiful
that way we can say everyone means
something instead of acknowledging that
beauty is not the only
person's value quick fact check quick
fact check we have here the dove real
beauty campaign which was average to
obese women and i think they even had
some some amputees yeah ben and jerry's
parent unilever
dove owner unilever
conspiracy confirmed oh boy it's
happening what i was going to say
i love what you just said and also the
times
even when i've been struggling whether
it's with depression
suicidal ideation uh
binge eating whatever it is
the times where someone actually made me
feel good about myself is when i would
lock in and want to double down yes the
times where i would just go you know
what i'm a fat piece of garbage well
then what does a fat piece of garbage do
he certainly doesn't train the next day
he feels bad he's got to fill the sad
hole in his heart so he starts eating
more food or you just go well this is
what everyone thinks i am anyway right
so sports illustrated you actually have
this opportunity to do something like
what you said but then also
write an article about hey you don't
think you're an athlete have you tried
these kind of sports have you tried
skateboarding have you tried jiu-jitsu
have you tried something i failed gym
class literally failed gym class in high
school i'll tell you how you get stoned
every day and pretend you don't have
your shorts it works
and then i found jujitsu at 17 and i was
like i always wanted to learn how to
fight because i grew up watching cheesy
martial arts movies and i fell in love
with jiu jitsu and accidentally became
an athlete because i found something i
loved you can help people you said you
felt so much better
did you like give up sugar cut out cut
out bread and sugar yeah and like i want
to ask you advice about that after the
show but it's because i'm feeling good
about myself
a heaping spoonful of almond flour a
heaping spoonful of walnut flour one egg
yeah mix it up microwave for one minute
boom you got a keto biscuit
then i cut it and i put cheese egg and
bacon on it and that's breakfast oh my
god actually sounds really good yeah
yeah all right you know i think i think
the issue is when you're younger you
need a bit more food especially if
you're athletic yeah for me one of the
issues was i used to eat like 8 000
calories per day because i would skate
for eight hours a day
and so it was just a machine when i got
older and started skating less and doing
you know news and stuff more
i still had the habits of eating big
meals
and then you know i gained weight from
it right right right so now i'm like i
still skate a lot but it's remarkable
that in the past yo bro i i it's
remarkable how little i eat relative to
what i was eating last year yeah and
it's crazy and you probably feel
great that's the thing when i'm eating
unhealthy
sure i could say you know i love my beer
good i love my whatever but i don't feel
well and i get depressed and i sleep
later which means i don't go to the gym
and the times where i'm training and the
times where i'm eating healthy
i feel good and you want people to feel
good
and again it's
you don't have to say
not beautiful
but man you can also encourage people to
be
healthy because you want them to feel
good you don't want them to be depressed
the times i'm eating like crap the times
i'm overweight it absolutely ties into
my depression it's horrible yes yeah
well and no one really
openly says this right they'll just
apply this principle to different
categories all the time and hope you
don't notice but there's this weird
pervasive idea that like everyone is
equal in every single way so no one's
smarter than anyone else no one's more
beautiful than anyone else no one's
stronger than anyone else and it's just
not true it's just not true now again
what we should be promoting and this is
certainly what i believe is that you
know humans are made in the image and
likeness of god every single person has
unfathomable value but instead
because we have limited people's value
to what they bring to us instead of what
they are
solely
without seeing them as full persons in
order to compensate for that we have to
say okay well yeah people really are
just their physical makeup and they
don't have any intrinsic value besides
these specific things we decide to
assign value to but they're all equal in
those categories so it's fine i'm not
caught up in the news who's this god
fella
well
that
so for those in the chat that are
getting triggered by my eating eight
thousand calories comments
i was being i was exactly hyperbolic
yeah i was saying like i'm eating an
exorbitant amount how are you not dead
eating eight pizzas but no i if uh but
but i will tell you it's like uh not
every day but days before and sometimes
after it would be excess of 3000
calories
and like
yo if i train twice a day i'm murdering
so
breakfast with like um
meat potatoes uh eggs toast you're
looking at like you know 800 with a
glass of orange juice or a thousand then
you then you've got lunch which was a
couple sandwiches and look at another
6-700 for dinner you get panda express
double orange chicken with a big thing
of rice
it's like three to five thousand
depending on what you're eating some
days we get like we could pan express
three times yeah
seriously skating for eight hours a day
drenched in sweat like i'm not kidding
man no a lot of my pro athlete friends
can eat garbage like there's a jiu jitsu
fighter who is famous for trying to get
a panda express sponsorship and there's
there's another one who only eats in and
out and five guys and stuff and they
look great and ripped and shredded but
they're i'm sure the inside of their
body is dying which by the way
it's you could put that dude on the
cover of sports illustrated and he'd
look great there's like the whole skinny
fat thing but again he will be dead at
40. yeah and that's why it was a red
pill for me i was like they clearly
don't care about women because they it
looks to me like they actually want them
to die young you can't tell me that you
want these women to see their
grandchildren looks like you don't even
want them to live past 40. i gotta say i
think it was bill maher who said this
but you don't see fat 90 year olds and
it's it's not to be me but it's it's
true it's very sad it's very sad it's
true you don't it's like well if you
care about people and you want to help
them live longer lives you should try to
encourage them and like you pointed out
in a healthy way you're don't be a jerk
about it
yeah yeah no one of my friends just hit
me up today about starting jiu jitsu and
he's a big dude and i wasn't just like
oh thank god fatty what is your wife not
doing you anymore i just literally
without saying it you know i left him a
voice memo on instagram and i was like
hey you're coming in with me i'll take
you into class i'll make sure you don't
have to pay let me make you feel
comfortable blah blah blah and i just
told him i told him i wasn't athletic
and jiu jitsu all the stuff i said to
you guys and it's like i'm so hyped to
help this dude and you know a lot of
people
who are overweight they just kind of
silently suffer and they hate themselves
and they feel and again i i've been
there on a million different levels um
and i don't think this stuff is helping
them again i think the sports
illustrated thing is harmless but i
think all that stuff that said like
healthy is just like liable yeah right i
think there's there's some harm in the
sports illustrated thing i just think
you know dr peterson went a little too
far like yeah i don't understand that
pull back a little bit you know like i
would i would put lol and be like no
thank you or something yeah
well no thank you even that though would
be like kind of a one that would be kind
of a wild tweet to see from jordan
peterson i was like oh
jordan he tweeted that he's like had his
staff change his password he's getting
away from temptation getting off twitter
because it's toxic and the barrage of
insults and i'm just i just i'm i'm
confused by that um
i got i get it
for some people having just millions of
people tweeting hateful things at you
you know some people can't handle that
tim loves it he's like
are you kidding like what i'm trending
right now i've been trending for like
four days straight and you know i do i
posted the elmo fire emoji like say my
name
this is this is what i need to
learn from i almost asked you this when
we were hanging out earlier but i wanted
to save it for the show yeah because so
i had john cleese on my podcast and like
a month or two ago and if you guys are
from monty python blah blah blah and
he's been cancelled a bunch this year
and he told me he doesn't know why and
he's like i don't look someone says hey
you're trending on twitter and he goes
all right i don't care and then he goes
and he lives with his you know monty
python money and lives a happy life
right what i think one of my problems
was that i couldn't take it mentally
like i was suicidal i did disappear and
stuff like that and so
now that i'm sort of
just diving into comedy and in comedy
you don't really care as much and you
can make things
jokes and that's all that matters
because my problem too was i was i was
just niche famous enough to get canceled
but like not famous enough to have a
savings account or like a pool
and so you know i see like john cleese
and i go well yeah you don't have to
look at twitter but i gotta get booked
at the chucklehud in kansas city and
have a you know creepy anonymous twitter
account like dming their gm and so
but i also think that part of the reason
you blew up was
that not caring and by you not caring
you were establishing your loyal fans
which i didn't do i just like peaced out
because i thought i was gonna die i i
come from the internet era of
you like trolling to like you go on
forums and you post things to get
attention right right so when i those
were the people that all called me cucks
i'll see like you know you know vosh
trends a whole lot as well
really yeah yeah yeah and so like i'll
see you know he'll be tweeting like like
a thousand four hundred those are rookie
numbers you gotta get those numbers up
but he had a funny tweet too he said i
forgot what he said but he said i have
i've i'm i'm gonna paraphrase but
something like i have stared to the eyes
of the of the beast and nothing scares
me more than this this monster and it
was a screen grab of bosh trending
you know look criticize the guy and all
that stuff i thought that was a funny
that's very funny but uh
when i yeah when i see like tin pool
trending and i'm like why is it so low
like come on man it's it's like it was
like three thousand nine hundred just a
little bit so what about when you if you
hate me get those numbers up baby what
about when you were like coming up
dealing with the hate or when you didn't
have as strong a network i mean the
truth is i literally just never cared so
so like when we started i care so much
guys
no but but look when we started doing
this show we were getting like uh i
don't know shy of a thousand concurrence
or something yeah i don't care i wanted
i wanted to do the show because i was
bored right like i want to do it right
and then people say nasty things about
you and they criticize you and you're
just like oh
i guess man
i grew up on the internet people say
nasty things all the time you also
always had because i realized one of the
reasons that i'm so confident right now
is because of those i have a solid
community for the first time in my life
in texas in jiu jitsu in comedy where i
have
my favorite comics are my friends even
just doing this with you guys i'm like
okay cool i have like new friends now um
my jujitsu community if people say
untrue things about me in jiu jitsu
unlike my old friends who were like well
i can't tweet about jamie i don't want
to lose my free internship at the nation
it's like these jiu-jitsu guys they
don't care at all they're like yo we
will go to war for you do you need us to
go to war for you do you need my lawyer
i will give you my lawyer like literally
doing things like that and so community
that's what i was going to say is i
wonder if even when you didn't have huge
fans you had your crew
and whereas i didn't have anybody no i
have no crew i mean like i go i show up
occupy by myself and for the most part
you know half the people got beat with
me half don't and i'm just like i'm
doing my thing and you just didn't care
yeah i don't care i never cared i mean
uh i i care about
like
i care about freedom personal
responsibility i care about truth i care
about that okay so what about when
people say stuff that isn't true because
that'll happen to me sometimes where
i'll post something and someone just
writes you were accused of sexual
assault and i want to just go no i
wasn't because i wasn't but i also don't
want to address it and that
is me i i agree i mean it's it's it's
annoying but then there's also like
a someone with a hundred followers will
say something that's not true and i'm
like okay i could respond to them and
try and convince one person or i can do
my show and convince a million right so
i'm just going to keep doing money just
getting bigger getting bigger thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
we'll see you all there
you